[Music]
hi there Heather here and hello again
from me Priyanka a customer engineer
here at Google on today's episode we'll
be discussing deployment manager as our
customers use cloud in bigger ways it's
becoming increasingly important to
simplify cloud management deployment
manager is an infrastructure deployment
service that automates the creation and
management of Google cloud platform
resources that's right and will also run
through a quick demo of the self-paced
lab or will use deployment manager to
create a simple configuration file use
that file to create a deployment then
view the deployment information on a
manifest so let's walk through how
deployment manager helps simplify cloud
management I like to think of deployment
manager as a cookbook combining all the
recipes into one place
exactly and think of each resource as a
recipe I like the fact that deployment
manager supports a repeatable deployment
process by creating configuration files
which define the resources the process
can be repeated over and over with
consistent results and keep in mind
declarative language can be used in
creating those configuration files I can
say exactly what I want the
configuration to be and I just let the
system figure out what steps to take
absolutely configurations can get really
complex a basic configuration file might
be enough for simple were close but for
more complex architectures and
configurations that you plan to reuse
you can break your configuration into
templates templates allow you to
separate your configuration out into
different pieces that you can reuse
across different deployments deployment
manager allows you to easily deploy
systems in a variety of locations and
provides control needed to easily roll
out new services it also gives you the
flexibility to deploy several versions
of your code simultaneously it also
allows you to change a deployment by
adding or removing resources and
updating properties of existing
resources
quick laps time in this lab you will use
the g-cloud command line tool to create
a simple configuration file use that
file to create a deployment then view
deployment information in a manifest you
can check out the link to start the
quick lab here keep in mind that this
will take about 30 minutes to complete
so far in the lab you've created a
configuration you've specified some
values in the VM gamma file such as your
project ID and the VM image to deploy to
deploy the configuration you run this
g-cloud command you will see the status
of your configuration while it's being
deployed upon completion you will see
the state change to complete you can
then view information about the
deployment by running the describe
command using the manifest ID output in
the last command you can see your
deployments manifest well there we have
it let us know how you use deployment
manager don't forget to keep visiting
our on-air webinar series our Quick labs
and our blogs all the links are below
you can also learn more about deployment
manager through our on-demand courses on
Coursera thanks for watching and we'll
see you soon see you check out our last
episode where we take a look at stock
driver we meet with Morgan the product
manager to discuss monitoring error
reporting and debugging